The last thing we're going to take a look at is how we would add some dynamic movement
to parts of our mesh, and namely that's going to be the cables of this mech character.
For that we'll use the addJiggle function first.
So let's see how we set that up.
So we're going to add jiggle to some of our toe cables here.
And for that we need to find the addJiggle function.
So let's just add one of those to the graph.
Oops, so I search for addJiggle.
And the jiggle function takes in two bits of information.
It takes in a child to jiggle, which is the bone or the rig element that you want to jiggle.
And it takes a control input, which is a control that we're going to create at the origin of
this bone that we're jiggling, because it's essentially going to use a spring interpolate
node to calculate a vector from the bone's current position to the control's current
position and add like an offset delay.
And you get control over the strength and critical damping to make the bone jiggle more
or jiggle less, giving you control over that delay.
So to set this up, let's give the function a control and a child to jiggle.
So with the foot here or the cable that we're trying to jiggle, the toe cord, I think it
would be the end one, yeah, toe cord 3, FR02L.
So that's going to be the bone that we want to jiggle.
So I'll just put that in there as a child to jiggle.
And I'm going to press control N to create a new control at the location of that bone.
And I'm going to parent it underneath the foot control that we have here, the Lego 4.
And that means that when we remove the leg or the foot, that control is going to come
with it.
Now if we select this control as our control to use our target, our vector target, and
then connect this up to the main logic here, what we should see when we move this foot
is that we now have jiggle on that bone there.
So it really is that quick and that simple to actually get jiggle or some sort of dynamic
movement set up on something like a cable on your mesh.
Now you have control over stuff like the stiffness, which is the strength here, and the damping,
the critical damping here.
So we could up that to 4, for example, to customize the look of this.
And we can see that it becomes a little bit faster now, a little bit more stiff, a bit
more rigid.
And if we increase the damping to 1, for example, you'll see that it doesn't have as much jiggle,
it doesn't have as much overshoot, it just slowly comes to rest.
So you can tweak these values until you get something suitable for your control rig and
for your character, depending on how big the chord is, how much you want it to move, and
things like that.
Now if you have a lot of cables like we do on here that we want to jiggle, what we could
do is if we select each one, let's try that again, select each one of these and press
control N to create a control for each of them and make sure they go inside the leg
control.
We can actually do a little bit more logic here to get them all moving together.
So we can do an item name search.
And what this is going to do is allow us to search for a partial name, so in this case
we'll do toe cord because that's the name of our controls.
And it'll also allow us to search for a type.
And in this case we're going to search for control.
And this essentially gives us an array with all of the controls inside the hierarchy that
contain toe cord in the name.
So what we're going to do is search for a four each, which is just saying, okay, for
each of the elements in this array, if I give us a bit more space, shrink that down a touch.
We're going to use this as the control for our control to jiggle.
And for the child, what we're going to do is use the name of the control, or actually
going to use a chop node to remove the last five characters from the name.
That way we'll be able to find the bones names.
If I put five on there, we'll take the remainder pin, plug that into our child to jiggle name
here, and then connect up the logic so that we're using that for each, and then using
the jiggle function.
And now what should happen is if we move this, you see that all of them start to jiggle and
all of them start to move.
And we've really not had to do a lot of logic here or make a lot of controls or anything
like that, or at least much manual work.
And to make this even more sort of organic and realistic, you could actually randomize
the strength of each one of these by using a random float.
And what we'll do is grab the index of this, which will grab an individual control that
we have in this array, and we'll plug that into the strength.
And we can say, okay, we want a minimum strength of two and a maximum strength of six, for
example.
If I compile that, what we should see now is that all of our feet bones, or our feet
cables, should I say, all react ever so slightly differently between random strengths of two
and six when we move the foot.
And it just gives you that little bit more of sort of organic movement, realistic movement,
and not seeing everything sort of mirrored or moving in unison together.
So that's a great way to add some dynamic movement to the cables on your mesh.
And as you can see, it's actually quite fast to get working.
Next we'll take a look at the chain dynamics to just see a different way of adding some
dynamic movement.